these men are hoping to find work I have
no work for you this Factory owner tells
them
the price of electricity has increased
making it more expensive to run
machinery and the collapse of Pakistan's
currency makes importing raw materials
very difficult now every day it doesn't
the factors are closing hundreds of our
workers are becoming jobless we even
don't have the money to give our
laxative bill that is the reason that
these factories looks like the graveyard
of the machinery and the reason is is
that our
government they are politicians they are
busy in the game of power the city of
Festival is famous for its factories but
now so many have been left jobless
where are we supposed to go how are we
to send our children to school and feed
them we can only work if there's work
the politicians are stuck in their own
politics no one cares about his workers
everyone in this city has felt the
impact of the crisis
this is one of the largest textile
factories in the country they produce
clothing for designer Brands they too
have had to lay off workers but they've
weathered the storm for now each
government comes with a different agenda
with a different subsidy package with a
different uh
policy so one thing which we can differ
from or which refers us from
comparators like other countries like
Bangladesh is the consistency and
implementation of a long-term policy to
ensure the sustainable growth of the
textile sector
the Pakistani government's discussions
with the IMF are said to include energy
subsidies for the textile industry some
worry that if those are cut or removed
things could get worse Pakistan
and has lots of poverty and unemployment
and because
street so many of us get work and run
our households especially important for
women because there aren't a lot of
opportunities generally
people here say there is so much
potential in the textile industry and it
can become a world leader if it's
supported by the government
with the coalition government still
debating the terms of a relief package
with the IMF the success or failure of
Pakistan's economy could hinge on the
textile industry that's why Business
Leaders here are urging the government
to protect it but most of all they want
political stability something that's
been missing in recent times
about Pakistan